de sport et solidarité une course était
organisée lundi 20 février pour soutenir
les populations
ukrainiennes un an après le début du
conflit avec la Russie environ 35 jogger
ont répondu à l'appel de l'enseigne
erroning situé à Conflans
fait que les gens ont aussi envie de se
mobiliser montrer que qu'on soutient à
notre niveau même si c'est symbolique
voilà montrer qu'on est rassemblé et
j'ai demandé à chacun de s'il pouvait
devenir habillé aux couleurs du drapeau
ukrainien c'est-à-dire en bleu et ou en
jaune j'aime bien le courir et ça aide
un peu à Montpellier j'ai fait avec
plaisir en mars 2022 une sortie
solidaire avait déjà été organisée par
le commerce sur ses propres fonds cette
année les 8 km parcourus ont permis
d'offrir 300 euros à l'association
tournesols
de chaussettes épais pour envoyer
l'Ukraine parce que ça ça m'a beaucoup
vêtements chauds des polaires etc j'y
suis là pour demander petit aide on peut
dire pour payer les camions tout
simplement tout au long de l'année
vêtements et chaussures sont collectées
par l'enseignement sportive pour aider
les populations défavorisées dans le
monde